hello and welcome to this video playing
dynamos 63 screen master Koosman right
yeah alexey kuzmin so let's see what we
get I've went for d44 change I don't
know if he plays the green fat all the
king's onion it's the Kings onion okay
mmm let me think about this a little bit
what lion do I want to try I really with
the age three line I really don't know
it all that well I think I'll go for a
sandwich for a change and see what he
has in store here he's a good
theoretical player let's see I think
with the the roof see one line is okay
this prevents beef I for the time being
okay so Bishop d7 what displayed he am
Center said 23 stuff
I think white first goes with this
maneuver here it's been a while since I
looked at this interesting ok after go
with this say otherwise I'll never
develop and night to d8 mr. Cruz mean is
that a good square probably not but it
will go to have seven I mean I play
something similar in the royer I have
played something similar Wow age five
okay well he's not threatening all that
much yeah I think with the age porn I
think I can do this um pentium and come
take I definitely want night coming to
be six of possible bishops on the seven
though I wonder how to react against f5
maybe I just take I can probably just
take
no I don't know take an f4i to us I
don't believe in blacks play at all I
think this is just not not very good the
Knights make a strange impression and he
has weakened as king a lot so this
should be quite nice for wide one thing
that I might have f4 and just take like
open it up um night to f7 okay so I'll
go where for here okay and I just
where's it going with this right right
Knight takes Knight xe5 this night see
for now ok I think I have to focus here
on the EF file if he shuts it down with
your I'm ok anyway what is he doing is
it really good I cannot believe it so
let's see him I have thought this six
but this is actually not working I'm at
least it doesn't feel like it's so clear
ok I can take upon ever i can just take
FYI can take as mentioned yeah and there
is still this d6 idea that's probably
not bad but it's also really a porn porn
I can also play 93 years a simple move
let's do this if intent Bishop c5 now
this is a bit bit simple what I'm doing
here but maybe it's enough I'm keeping
the time a little bit in mind I've spent
a bit too much time and yeah need to
catch up a little bit maybe Nyjah force
what it tries to do no no it doesn't
okay so let's do let's do this right the
69 FYI it looks that looks bad just
looks bad on my deform mine later for
Scott is 96 awesome
maybe he's trying to sec but I'm not
even taking if you would have sacked
yeah this is not easy now 'if I've Hanks
not g6 hangs the night is pinned I think
like flex play was extremely Lucia it's
murky still here of course it's a
typical Kings Indian murkiness around so
I can d 6 take this 6 and grab grab
material here Knight to e5 1935 is also
interesting to take the seven yeah not
sure both makes quite some sense
taking these seven the idea is to get to
have get to f5 to break this paw
information down also okay that that
opens office Bishop of course but yeah I
don't mind that much Queen g5 to try to
take f5
you
maybe 97's to the move yeah I was I
wanted to play rookie for but he has
Queen to see six it's a shame
I'm warning yeah I know maybe I
shouldn't have given him giving him that
corn here but ok um so age 7 ideas
Bishop f5
rook g ade almost winds almost g8 Knight
takes to double check check again
there's no win that's it's really a
shame that's a shame
now Luke g8 bloody ruchi adium is he
swindled out of this stuff that's not
fair you know it's really not fair
okay so it's it's okay again just have
no time black forfeits on time I know
but he's got less time I'm even okay so
it had the result that it should have
had but I didn't didn't play that well
of course from here should end quite
quite simply but it didn't okay so let's
have a look I don't believe in blacks I
love I have to admit this is this 98 and
so on I mean okay it's a typical Kings
Indian murkiness but I don't really see
what h5 did if you want to play for f5
you don't need to move okay this should
be in some way better for wider the
engine gives me how a pawn yeah i don't
know i'm happy i think my position is
quite ammonius and it's always some
difficult to play for black f what never
works due to the pin okay when b5 and 93
now allows this idea so here here and
now the engine gives night you for okay
that that seems to be an improvement oh
yeah okay I'm air can do that but he
takes us and I understand this is
probably not all that great right
because now if the night moves there's a
check wave or taking okay so maybe I
have to check with the Queen yeah this
is interesting for mmm that's
interesting I mean black as a pawn down
but he's extremely active now so
probably I didn't play it play it
correctly Jim okay I mean I don't want
to make a huge analysis here from here
the position is winning four wide and I
think this also was ok glad it I just
have to kill him here somehow yeah I
played that work g one was winning okay
Sam and now I can I cannot take that's
really a shame it always has this this
weird pen but rookie one is right it's
correct them because this is also an
idea we have the check this have root d6
now I don't quite get the move what is
the point of this who gave six maybe
this one okay I had to force this move
may be now okay why do white is like
completely winning word this is not so
easy i put the bone up and like here the
group jaded at it it looks strong if
it's double check but there's no
follow-up can just about save it yeah
it's just so just too murky murky
situation oh he have Queen takes okay
it's funny a lot of I considered yeah
and Bishop f5 winning says the engine
but who's who's playing this stuff yeah
not with no time here the computer gives
equal yeah yeah I'm winning actually but
should be three should win okay I of
course i miss stuff here who have six
wins I have 10 seconds so it was mostly
a time play yeah probably at the end not
an undeserved victory but still a very
murky game ok guys thanks for watching